hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry and I'm
Michelle Q welcome to reasons to see
where we give you reasons to see and not
to see so let's hang out Ryan's
consensus there are a lot of reasons to
see mama there are a lot of reasons to
see mama there are a lot of reasons to
see mama
jeurys consensus there are some strong
reasons to see mama there are some
strong reasons to see mama michelle's
consensus there are a lot of reasons to
see mama there are a lot of reasons to
see marlin reason to see number one the
horror this film did scare me a lot I
was very scared throughout a good amount
of it it's not consistently scary it's
mainly jump scares I would say it's
definitely got a creepy vibe and a cool
sort of eeriness about it which which I
really like
as far as scares go there are some there
are a couple really good jump scares
that I jumped and was like when she goes
into the closet yeah I thought mama was
pretty scary and I liked how you
actually see mama early on like they
establish that no it's a ghost guys and
there are times where it's scary where
they're not even really trying to be
scared some of the horror is kind of
funny at times when Lilly is tugging on
the sheet yeah it's scary but it's also
kind of funny at the same time like
there's a certain type of enthusiasm to
the scares that I really enjoyed in that
scene has to be established we have the
relationship between Lilly and Mama that
mother and her child you know
playfulness which when they do a good
job with that you know psychological
element it's weird I've never cared so
much about children before that also
scared the living [ __ ] at me I like that
they had that intro because it
immediately establishes sympathy and
humanity for these kids before it turns
them into complete animals yeah because
it Robbie's makes that possible and
their animalistic qualities actually
make sense
to the store it makes sense the way they
move it's not like they're just weird
supernatural freaky little kids based
off their upbringing based off who they
who's been raising them it actually
makes perfect sense of what's going on
yeah and why they yeah cuz they move
like creepy little [ __ ] it's almost
like an animal pack where it's like you
know she that whole thing where they
first discovered them in the cabin and
she likes cuddles up on top of the
fridge or whatever I am the younger
sister scuttles up underneath her and
they're sort of protecting each other
it's kind of a fantasy type of horror at
the same time you can almost call it the
legend of mama it's a total fairy tale I
mean jump scares you know I mean people
call that cheap because it doesn't stay
away anyone can make somebody jump by
making loud sounds and cutting to
something so I get why people complain
but at the same time it's a component of
horror and it serves its purpose and as
it stands this is a movie that's like a
jump-scare
around every corner like there is some
suspense and like I said part of the
horror that I enjoyed the most in this
is all the eerie sort of creepy stuff
the fear is very menacing throughout the
whole entire movie there's this threat
of when is mama gonna come out what's
mom gonna do next and which side are
these children on are the children for
you know Hannah Bella Luke or are they
for mama what's gonna happen with them
are they kind of doing some type of
manipulation when you're seeing it
through
Mama's point of view that dream sequence
where they're showing you you know where
she stabs a nun and everything like that
that was just fantastic to me
yeah it's creepy it's kinda scary even
though you're seeing it through her
point of view it's still kind of scary
to look at the individuals aid with that
that's why I like the jump scares
because the jump scares are usually
backed up with some type of creepy
visual at the same time reason to see
number two the directing and the writing
it's rare where you get a horror movie
that is so character based every
character in this film I thought was
fully fleshed out from Jessica Chastain
to Luke to the little girls even mama is
actually a fleshed out character it
makes sense what's going on there
I feel like Jessica Chastain and mom are
the ones who get the most fleshing
because Luke disappears for a lot of the
movie but regardless you still
understand his intent you still
understand
what he feels the way he feels I like
how Annabelle and Luke have this real
relationship that's going on where Luke
is so focused on doing this for the
children and trying to find these kids
see what's up man Annabelle is kind of
distancing herself from the relationship
and she wants to be lead her own type of
life and she's constantly being thrown
into these situations and with the fairy
tale aspect it's almost like it was fate
for her to be put into the situation or
by the end of this movie she's willing
to sacrifice her life pretty much to
save these kids we're who she originally
is like I don't really want anything to
do with these kicking scene now oh yeah
because it's a shake-up on her lifestyle
you know and and their lifestyle because
they're not equipped for that anyway so
you know and that's where the most
growth comes from her choice to her
bonding with the kids and also with
where the kids decide to go to because
this movie in a lot of ways you could
almost call it a psychological horror
film at times as well because they've a
there's a lot of psychology they infuse
into a ghost story which you don't often
see you usually got some type of
paranormal expert that comes along this
time it's like no they got a
psychologist expert who comes along
hypnotherapy sessions with the children
to try to figure out who this moment is
calling it a split personality
rather than being like come on you
idiots can't you tell it's a ghost it
makes perfect sense why they're assuming
the schizophrenia and everything like
that and when they have those moments
where they're in their observation room
and you see the children talking to mama
you see them in the footage the audience
knows like they're really talking to a
ghost you guys that's the thing I kind
of didn't fully get actually is the fact
that they can see mama and there is a
point where someone says like she
doesn't want you to see her or something
so she's like she has stopped mama hides
yeah so I I did have to at one point be
like if they're talking to her now and
people seem to see them later on like
why can't we see her now because
remember this Victoria tells I think she
tells the therapist that mama lives in
the wall that's why they're talking to
the walls cuz they're like calling for
her yeah maybe they see the moth thing
forming on the wall possibly I guess
didn't fully get addressed for me so I
did well it's only a little thing and I
was fine with it because at that point
the movie you don't really know much
about how the mama operation really
works you can't assume like oh maybe
only the children can see her so when
she starts appearing to other people it
makes it that much scarier felt at least
momentarily like bending the rules to
make it scarier for a minute yeah I
could give you that I adored the ending
of it it made sense like they stuck true
to all the things they established and
the way the children decide to go and
there's a students in Vienna I thought
was a cool way to go instead of saving
both of them and having one big happy
family it's like no the younger one is
gonna go with mom okay guys all she
knows when this film is dealing so much
with psychology you cannot ignore the
way how human beings would actually
function when the little girl Lily is
being raised by a ghost as a baby of
course she's gonna associate her as as
her mother she's not going to go oh
that's a ghost it's scary she's gonna
know it as her mother and Victoria is
probably able to discern the difference
because she actually has vague memories
of what it's like to have real parents
and a real family and through going
through the process with Annabelle Luke
of course she's gonna like start being
more attached to that because that's
what she originally grew up with to
begin with well they make that a good
transition she sees Luke and then that
reminds her of her father and then that
brings something back and then they give
her her glasses and it's you know she
broke her glasses on the way to the
cabin which is a cool little you know
way to bring it back and also it struck
me that she's never actually fully seen
what mama looks like because her vision
is so bad yeah so I think that's another
thing that helps to sort of ground her
in the the you know like civilized world
it's like when she starts actually
seeing what mama looks like it's not
like it's terrifying to her but it does
seem like it could be a little bit like
oh that's Ben there's a part in the
movie where she actually like takes off
her glasses before going into the room
where Lily's playing with mama kind of
like she's choosing so that she can
maintain I guess this idea of mama
further along in the movie you notice
she does not take off her glasses
anymore when Mama's around that's almost
like an act of defiance because it's a
gift from them who's trying to take her
away from mom and that's you and she
smashes them ones that whole big attack
sequence
like oh she's seen she's starting to see
more clearly now yeah you know it's yeah
it's a good symbol of symbolism yeah her
glasses broke right when her world went
a different direction than when she
comes back to the you know civilized
world you know she gains her vision back
the story is kind of familiar but I
thought they did a kind of a fresh take
on it you know bringing the fairy tale
elements into it and not just making it
like some long drawn-out tension film
because there's a lot of different
layers in it sometimes it's just
dramatic sometimes it's emotional
sometimes it's scary sometimes it feels
like a fantasy you know they got a lot
of different themes going on and the
director Andre machete something like
that you never pronounce the guy's last
name or his first name I always get it
wrong you know like Ohio people are
looking at Guillermo del Toro but I feel
a lot of the credit actually goes to him
because he's like Oh story trader of it
he's the co-writer he's the director
it's this is really his film and he did
an excellent job at it you know it
definitely has del Toro's horror fantasy
stamp on it
you can see why he presented this movie
yeah and there's a ton of Spanish crew
it's also yeah you definitely got to
give under English Yeti credit because
even if the script isn't fully up to it
the direction is like it's really well
directed movie and it makes you excited
to see what he's gonna do next you know
in some ways it really actually brought
to mind the legend of La Llorona because
it's the same kind of idea of a woman
who if you just murders four kids and
the legend is like you know you got to
be wearing light on that because she's
gonna take you and the night you know
and make you her kid and then eventually
kill you and that's kind of essentially
what's going on with mama here I didn't
even see yeah that's what I mean there's
some like there's some homage aspects
going on in this film they don't really
do enjoy some people are calling this
like confusing it hard to follow but I
don't really think it is confusing and
hard to follow
you know the main story is there are
some things in the third act where I
felt like something had been cut out or
missing his whole thing where where
Luke's brother shows up
yeah and he's our teacher he's like come
to the catacomb wrap it up
and then I'm like why did you go yeah we
not were we gonna you know cuz cuz I
felt like they opened on him and then
they brought him back the brother in it
in some way and I thought they were
gonna do something with that so that the
brothers get a moment or some kind of
confrontation of at least the emotion
there happens and then he sort of goes
out into the woods and then he just
meets her when she comes to the woods
the only person I fully bought their
trip into the woods for was Jessica
Chastain's character was Annabel cuz
like then I was like yes you have like a
perfect reason to go right now to the
woods it's like why does everybody leave
at like 5:30 when it's going to be doing
it always made sense why they went there
and what they did but the thing that
never made sense is why are you going in
so late at night
why are you going so late and why are
you lost why do you not seem like you
know where this is even though people
have already found it and you have
reason to see number three
cinematography the cinematography was
beautiful look yeah from the beginning
yeah of the movie you know like that
just that moment where those children
are sitting by the fire in the cabin and
then mama rolls the cherry to them from
that moment I was like wow what
beautiful cinematography we're looking
at right now well they played a lot with
color and stuff like that like you
noticing the color balances on each on a
lot of the scenes change from like blues
to Gold's to these winter Gray's yeah
yeah there are some really stylized
moments that are that are really cool I
mean there's there's a moment in the
cabin where where all the horror is
happening through like the flashes of a
camera and there is an even better
there's the dream sequence that is shot
in a way that makes it look like an old
photograph but it's still but it's
moving and you know like I saw the
shortest movies based on and and dude
clearly knows what he's doing with
imagery and this movie takes that to
another level in a really cool way the
cinematography enhances the creepy
aspect and enhances the fantasy aspect
every single type of genre theme that
are going for the cinematographer and
the director really seem to be on the
same level to what they were trying to
achieve with not just the look but the
tongue
they just nailed the tone down reason to
see number four great performances I
have to start off with talking about
those two little kids yeah I mean if
nothing else yeah you haven't mentioned
them but you're compassionate for them
when the director wants to be
compassionate for them and they scare
that [ __ ] out of you who and yeah the
rector wants you to be scared shitless
from them they're great they're there
believe I could have bought them as like
they cast two real sisters together yeah
I think they pull some incredible
performances out of them and you know
for such young ages and I mean that goes
on on them and working with the director
I imagine because you know I'm sure they
didn't put them in all those scary
situations necessarily but it really
comes across and they they're fantastic
yeah cuz like when when Lily is being a
young child it's it's believable it
isn't and then when she's also being you
know showing more for traumatized sides
and her fearful sides that that's also
believable and when she's being a creepy
little [ __ ] it's also but we don't know
you know what I mean yeah and same thing
with Victoria when she's this girl with
at that age with that kind of level of
confusion and trauma like wow the the
emotion emitted from them is so
believable when both those girls without
those two girls this movie would not
have been as believable yeah and it's
great performances throughout not just
her you know Jessica Chastain who is
solid and zero dark thirty she's she's
great again I like to think of this as
the sequel to zero yeah so what did she
doesn't afterwards if she goes home
starts a band as her hair really goes
all out I love that look on her know she
I'm just gonna say tatted up punk chick
is ya know Jessica Chastain that's what
so actually the believable in it cuz the
last movie I saw of her was her gar 30
and then I see this and very believable
very very different and yet she's subtle
but you don't really realize how great
of a performance she actually does in
this movie until you reflect back on the
film and then you're like wow what a
whole arc that she actually goes through
from beginning to end at this person
whose wants to distance herself from all
this to willing to sacrifice her life at
the end like bets that's powerful
the way how she does the whole the whole
art it's very believable when she's
becoming mother like becoming more of an
adult she's kind of like kiddush in the
beginning yeah and to see her like grow
up throughout this film you know this
through this journey mama could also be
about her and in a way you know like the
reference of the title could be towards
her as well you know but come in a mama
taps into her maternal instincts
yeah actually clearly at the beginning
of the movie had no intention tapping
into those instincts and the guy played
loose yeah he's really good in it too
you know he's not one of those standout
performances but he's a good he's a
really sympathetic role in it yeah I
mean he's got a mode especially I mean
he put he technically plays two
characters so you know that opening
scene like I bought him to like they
they don't expand a whole lot on that
element of the story safe to say that
he's clearly a very disturbed disparate
state but I mean he's not in a ton of it
but when he is you know he's he's he's
always good and this psychologist too is
also solid as well yeah you know he
managed to be if he fit though the genre
of this film just right because he's not
like a creepy psychologist although at
times he's a little bit creepy he's not
creepy but it but you you have to wonder
what his intent is with all this yeah
you know is is he is he kind of greedy
about it does he really care
obviously he goes like he goes a little
bit crazy with his journey but even him
like descending into the madness of
these children's lives and was also very
believable just just the routes what
decisions visual effects now mama was
very visual effects and mama scared me
like as far as mama goes she scared the
crap out of me with the cinematographer
you're working with the visual effects I
thought that made her look that much
more real and believable to me had a
fantasy aspect to it so I actually
really enjoyed the visual effects on her
and I don't think if the visual effects
were as good on her I don't think I
would have been as scared of her well
I'd go back and forth because there are
times I think she looks good in this
movie and then there are times where I'm
a little distracted by like that's a CG
creature would it pull you out well
the fact I was sitting there noticing it
was kind of a pullout I mean it didn't
it didn't keep me from enjoying the film
overall cuz I really enjoyed it
I saw the short and the way they look
make mama look in the short is entirely
like like unnerving and this was a
little more flowy and ethereal and still
sinister but there were certain moments
that didn't feel like they absolutely
needed a be CGI like I feel like they
could have made her face all warped and
strange prosthetic Li and there were
certain times where her face looked that
way like I know for the hair and stuff
you got to do it but there were times
where it it felt apparent that it I was
watching a CG creation see I was never
put wherever pulled out by it no I
actually really liked that aspect of her
because it making it seem more mythical
it kind of like pulls you out of the
sense that it's not super real because
usually with like when it comes to
paranormal movies I get freaked the [ __ ]
out like I cannot watch it because I'm
so scared it's gonna happen to me in
this situation
she was very scary she was menacing but
at the same time the fact of how she
looked at made it seem like scary within
the realms of the movie not as it
applies to me what you made me feel a
lot more comfortable because then I
could actually enjoy the movie better
without freaking out if I was gonna
sleep at night or not but I really liked
that and actually that really reminded
me of the type of portrayal of the
supernatural in the orphanage I think
she was still really creepy and her
movements and even though she might have
looked a little CG esque it really
didn't for me it didn't pull me out I
maybe I really bother me much like oh I
wish they'd made her Moore's you know
realistic looking I don't think it
really gave the right tone to the movie
personally it's fair I think it I think
also partly it's I feel like it kind of
takes away from what stuff they may have
done practically that then doesn't look
quite real because of that like it's
sort of a blend like I'm all for mixing
CGI and practical like I'm down with
that it's just there were certain times
or I wasn't entirely convinced by what I
was looking at I guess but really
because I felt like the effects of it
because it
sometimes very cgi to me I felt it
blended in with a realm so well that it
actually enhanced it more because I
don't know what it ghost looks like I
have no idea but I imagine it looks kind
of surreal it looks a little bit like
whoa what that doesn't look real to me
you know what I mean yeah I mean cuz it
looks unnatural and it looks like things
ought not to look hmm
and I'm all for that conceptually
because they mean I think that's what
they were trying to achieve with the way
her limbs move and the faces misshapen
her eyes are too close together I'm all
for that design wise it's just and I'm
not saying the effects are bad I'm just
saying I didn't fully I wasn't like
that's a killer effects job when I when
I left the movie I was like there were
some times where I really liked the
effect there were some times where I was
kind of like oh you know I I wasn't
fully sold about what they do with the
effect that's my decision to reach their
own
hey subscribe subscribe or else Mama's
gonna come and eat you yeah
subscribe and these and subscribing